Hi.
In this lesson, we will be creating a masked material
starting from two different sets of textures.
OK, well, actually, before that, we'll
just dive into a little bit of theory
on masked materials and textures,
but it will just take two seconds, I promise.
OK?
Let's go.
So first of all, by masked materials,
I refer to the process of masking specific sets
of textures that correspond to various materials
within a single primary material.
So basically, integrating two materials into one
and then telling Unreal when to show one or the other.
And a common method that we will be exploring today
for accomplishing this involves
using the Material Editor to blend textures
with different values using an alpha mask.
And then this mask will delineate
the boundaries between two or more distinct surfaces.
And another technique commonly used for optimization purposes
in games, because it's really important
to hit that 30 or 60 FPS target, implies
the use of the red, green, and blue channels of a texture
to store different texture data.
These type of image textures are commonly
called packed textures, with the most common packing
convention in modern game engines
being the ORM textures, planning for occlusion, roughness,
and metallic, where the red channels store
the occlusion, the green, the roughness, and the blue,
the metallic maps of a material.
Also, just for you to know, Megascans
differ from the ORM approach, because they
store the displacement map in the blue channel.
I know, they're all a little different.
And normal maps are typically included separately
in their own texture, because they
need all three channels for the x, y, and z components
of the normal vector.
Even though for extreme cases, the blue channel
is sometimes repurposed, since it
can be reconstructed from the red and green channels
to make a normal map.
And then we have the alpha channel,
which is usually left unused in most common packed texture
workflows for memory efficiency and compression quality.
But it is commonly used for foliage or vegetation
as an opacity mask, for example.
And to be honest, the alpha channel
is really used for masking purposes most of the time.
But really, the way a texture is packed is up to what
you're trying to achieve.
And an incredible example of texture usage
can be found in an environment included in the project
file for this class.
Because this project was designed as an experiment
to build an environment using one major material with one
texture only.
And the entire scene, I know it sounds crazy,
but utilizes only two main textures, one dedicated
to diffuse and mask maps, and the other one to normals.
And the materials make extensive use
of masking and different UVs technique
that we will now see in the engine.
When we first fire up the project provided
with this class, this map will be opened by default,
map 201 underscore 1.
And if we navigate to the back, you
will find the environment I was just referring to.
And pretty much everything in this room
has been textured using one single packed texture.
Isn't that crazy?
Right, and I think that the best example
to showcase this material is probably this fellow over here,
which is a packed level actor.
Now, a packed level actor acts as optimized container
for all these different meshes.
You'll have to double click on it in order to access
the individual meshes.
But since those are instanced actors,
we don't really have access to their assigned materials
directly from the Details panel of the viewport.
We'll have to fire up this packed level
blueprint directly from the Blueprint editor.
So let's do that.
I'm just going to have the BP Planet Maker selected,
and then click on Edit BP Planet Maker in Blueprint.
OK, this will open the Blueprint editor.
And I will just navigate to the Viewport panel
to see the different instanced meshes over here.
OK, I will select one of them, like this little guy
over here.
And now we'll have to go through a few bunch
of submenus to access the material that was
assigned to this instanced mesh.
So just bear with me, but we'll get there
and it will be worth it.
So in the Child Actor Component section,
I'll open up the Child Actor Templates submenu.
Then go to Static Mesh Actor, Static Mesh Component,
Rendering, and we're almost there, Override Materials.
And here you will find the material assigned
to this individual instanced mesh.
So this is a material instance.
So we'll have to open it up by double clicking on it.
And here on the right in the Details panel,
I will find its parent material,
which is one texture base.
If I open it up, we won't go too deep, like deeper
than this, and break down this material for now.
But I just wanted to show you
that there is one main texture assigned
to it, which is a packed texture with different texture
data for the R, G, and B channels that are used here.
And then we have this normal texture over here.
So two main textures.
And let's go back to BP Planet Maker
and see the different materials assigned
to the different meshes.
So if I select this one over here,
you can see that there is another instanced material,
which is MI Compart.
So if I double click it, well, we find out
that they have the same master material,
which is one texture base.
And pretty much everything you're going to click here
is going to have either an instanced material
or the one texture base master material.
And that's pretty incredible.
So that was it.
We can go back to our exercise now.
Okay, you can find in the upcoming slides
the steps to follow along with the exercise,
but let's just jump ahead into the engine.
All right, so in this scene,
we can find a mask material in the Masking Texture section.
And if we zoom in, you can see that this material masks
golden parts and wax wooden parts.
And what's actually pretty cool to see
is how these two materials react to light.
So you can see that the gold has these bright hotspots
while the wax wood has these clear and sharp reflections.
We're actually going to be building this material
from scratch in just a second,
but I just wanted to show you a little trick
because this material came in
with a pretty imperfect alpha mask texture,
but we managed to fix it up
with just switching one little parameter
in the Texture Editor.
So I'm just going to be opening that up
to show you what we did.
I'm going to be opening the sample masking material
and then the texture over here.
Okay, so if I keep this window overlaid,
I'm just going to be zooming into an area
of the material where the transition
between the gold and wood is pretty evident,
like this golden square over here.
Okay, so in the Compression,
we have a Compression Settings parameter
that will switch from default to BC7.
So you keep on looking here at this edge over there,
and I'm just going to be reverting it
back to its default settings.
Okay, do you see here
all these alpha impurities over there?
Yeah, that's what I was referring to before.
And what we did was basically
just switching this Compression Settings
from default to BC7,
and that actually fixed up
most of the impurities of this texture.
So that's all I wanted to show you,
is just a little trick built in engine,
but it's pretty useful to know.
So now we can start creating our material.
I'm just going to create a material here
in the Content Browser,
and call it m-underscore-masking-demo.
You can call it whatever you like,
and then opening it up.
All right, so first thing we need is the textures
that build up this material.
So in the Content Browser,
you can find the wooden textures
under Base Assets, Textures, and Floor.
And we can drag and drop this into the Material Editor.
And then the golden textures can be found
under Megascans, Surfaces, and Gold.
And then what we need is the albedo,
the metallic, the normal, and the roughness.
Okay, drag and drop them into the Material Editor.
Cool.
So the first thing we're gonna need to take care of
is the base color.
I'm just going to be dragging the albedo
of the gold out here, pop,
the alpha mask over there in the middle,
and then the wooden base color down there.
And this other five for now we don't need,
so I'm just gonna move them to the side here.
All right, so I'm noticing one little thing here,
that this alpha mask is actually the opposite
of what we need.
We will need to invert it.
We would like the blacks to be where the whites are,
and vice versa.
And guess what?
There is one node that is actually pretty useful
to invert a texture, which is called the one minus node.
So if I drag out of the RGB output here,
and then just type one minus,
I can actually preview this node
by clicking on this down arrow over here.
And you see, it actually creates an inverted texture
based on the RGB output that we just gave it.
And that's amazing,
because now we can just multiply the golden base color
with this one minus node.
And if we preview it,
you can see that the golden parts got applied
to the white parts, which is what we wanted.
And now we can add to this multiply
the base color of the wood,
which will actually be applied
if you preview it to the black areas.
Amazing.
So just remember that these add and multiply nodes
actually really work like the blending layers in Photoshop.
So whether you apply the add or the multiply
one after the other or vice versa, it actually matters.
And if I had added first and then multiplied later,
I wouldn't have gotten a different output.
So just keep that in mind.
So the add output, I connect it to the base color.
And here we're still getting our mass material,
even though most of the heavy lifting
will actually be done by the roughness and metallic part,
because they will define
how these two materials react to light.
As we also already mentioned in the theory
in the second class of this course.
Okay, so another thing that I wanna do
is just turning off the specular,
because as I just mentioned,
most of the work is done by the metal and roughness maps.
So I'm going to be direct clicking on the specular
and then promote this to our parameter.
And I know that this now looks a little bit matte,
but we can always amp it up
after we set up the metallic and roughness maps.
So for now, let's just do it like this.
Okay, so now we need to take care of the metallic map.
And I said map, not maps,
because there is just one metal in this material.
And that's the gold.
So I'm just going to be taking this gold metallic map.
We're going to be using a very useful node
to be masking the golden metallic areas
with the wooden matte areas.
And that's called lerp or linear interpolate node.
So if we press L and left click on the graph,
you can create this lerp node,
which really works like a 50-50 blend with an alpha input
that can be used for masking purposes.
So I'm going to be plugging the RGB to the A of the lerp
and guess what the alpha is going to be?
Exactly what we used here as mask.
And since we're going to be reusing these two nodes
multiple times in the graph,
but I don't want to have a noodle fest,
I'm going to be introducing a really useful node,
which is called name reroute declaration node.
I know it's a bit of a mouthful.
So if I drag out of this output pin
and then type named reroute declaration node here,
we can create this node that actually is,
it's basically like a variable used in the Blueprint editor.
It basically stores this input
like a variable as I just said,
and lets us reference it anywhere in the graph
while keeping this graph clean.
So that's what we're using it for.
I'm just going to call it RGB alpha mask.
Okay, so now if we go down here to the lerp node
and I just right click in the graph,
I have this super useful named reroutes option up here.
And if I open up the menu,
I can find the RGB alpha mask variable
that we just created.
I'm just going to call it variable for now
for simplicity purposes.
Okay, and then I'm going to plug the RGB alpha
to the alpha and preview it.
But something is off
because these two outputs actually look the same,
these two previews.
And that's because we should apply the RGB to the B,
not the A because the A and B inputs of the lerp
are actually different.
So I'm just going to show you a little shortcut.
If I hold control and then hold left click
while clicking on the A input of the lerp,
you can see that I just start moving around
this RGB output noodle anywhere I want to.
So I can just plug it to the B input of the lerp.
And now the preview looks like we want it actually,
we want the goal to be applied
to the white areas of the mask.
Okay, so we can plug the lerp output
to the metallic up there.
And you can see that it starts applying
this little sheen on the golden parts of the material,
which is pretty cool.
So I'm just going to expose a scalar parameter here
by pressing one and left click on the graph
and then connecting it to the A.
So this A input basically represents
the wooden parts of the material,
which I'm not metallic,
but I'm just going to expose it just in case
if you want to test some stuff out later on.
Okay, so now what we need to do
is taking care of the roughness maps.
I'm going to be taking the wooden roughness
and the golden roughness.
We're basically going to recreate this same approach.
So I'm just going to be selecting
the RGB alpha mask variable and the lerp,
and then Ctrl D down here to duplicate them.
Then I'm going to be plugging
the RGB of the wood roughness map to the A
and the RGB of the gold roughness map to the B.
Then the output of this lerp node for the roughness maps
I'm just going to be plugging it into the roughness.
And now we start seeing some magic happening
because now you can see how the gold
is actually differently reacting to the light
compared to the wood,
getting this masked effect.
Okay, so now I think that the wood
might be a little bit too matte.
So in the specular here that we turned off,
I'm just going to be amping it up a little bit
and turning it up to 0.5.
Now we have this waxed wood look,
which I like quite a lot actually.
Okay, we're just missing one last bit,
which are the normal maps.
So I'm just going to select these two
and I'm just going to be dragging them down here.
We could be using the same exact approach
that we did here with the lerp and the alpha mask,
but I'm just going to be showing you a material function
that actually is more effective at blending normals
compared to the lerp.
And I know, I know, we'll be talking about
the material functions in two lessons,
but I'm just going to anticipate you this one.
So I'm going to be right clicking here in the graph
and then add a material function called
Blend Angle Corrected Normals.
And if I hover over this blue band over here,
it just says that it corrects the normal direction
of a normal map that is overlaid on another normal map.
Okay, what does this mean?
So this node blends one normal change into another
and it actually does a pretty good job at it.
The transition between one normal and the other
is actually nicely corrected according to
our camera point of view, so where we see
where we're looking the material from.
And that's actually not a harsh transition.
So I'm going to be connecting the RGB output
of the wood normal map to the base normal,
and then the RGB output of the gold normal map
to the additional normal.
And the result of that is going to be plugged
into the normal up here.
Okay, so now I'm just going to be doing something.
I'm just going to be double clicking
on this little noodle of the normal that I have this here
and then I'm going to be zooming into an area
of the material where we have a transition
because I just want to show you the difference
between the maps applied and not applied.
So if I add a shortcut Alt and left click
on the normal input of the material,
I can just unplug this pin.
And now you can see that the normals are off.
And if I plug it in again, you can see that they're on.
It's not actually a crazy difference.
It's actually just highlighting the edges a little bit,
but I think it will be more evident
in when using some stronger normal maps.
I just wanted to show you this approach
because it's a bit more efficient
than the lerp in this case.
Okay, so with some lerp nodes,
we managed to simply mask two different materials
and create this pretty cool gold and wooden mass material.
And now I'm just going to be saving
and applying that to our scene
by drag and dropping it into our preview mesh.
And here we go.
So in this last exercise we just explored,
we used four different image textures
and their base color to get access to the roughness,
metallic, and normal maps.
But as anticipated, you can embed different maps
directly into the three RGB channels,
like in this texture sample over here in the slide
that we also have available in our project.
I am in the masking textures,
RGB channels section of the default map.
And here we can see that these four,
actually six planes have different materials
assigned to them.
But we'll see in just a second
that these six different materials have been created
using one single packed image texture.
So if I select one of them and then in the details panel
open up the material assigned to it,
I can see in the material editor
that we have one single texture sample
with the red channel connected to the roughness
and the blue channel connected to the albedo or base color.
So this means that this one single image
has different maps embedded into the channels.
So let's open this texture down here in the details panel
and up here you can start isolating
the different color and alpha channels.
So I will be turning all of them off
and then I will isolate the red channel for now
to show you that it's storing our roughness map.
Then I'll isolate the green channel
to show that it's probably storing a metallic map.
The blue channel is storing a bump or height map
and the alpha channel as anticipated in the theory
is probably storing a mask.
Just for you to know,
you can easily pack different images
into the individual channels
using any image editing software.
You just need to select the channel individually
and then paste the gray scale texture
you need into that channel.
And yes, I said gray scale
because it's important to remember
that each RGB channel individually
only stores gray scale values and not color information
because the color is actually created
by the combination of the R, G, and B channels.
I'm going to go back for a moment to the material
and I said before that the red channel
should be used for roughness
but this doesn't mean that you have to use
the red channel for roughness.
In fact, I could be easily connecting it
directly into the base color
or I could just be multiplying the red and green channel
and then connect that into the albedo
and then the red channel to the roughness
and the B to the metallic.
The combination of these different channels
are really infinite.
In fact, this specific texture was used
to texture all the environment of the spaceship
we saw earlier in the theory class
and that's how crazy powerful these packed textures are.
All right, that was it for the class
and at this link you can find
other extensive documentation and resources
to further expand your knowledge
in mass materials and textures.
In the next class, we will be learning
about material functions,
creating an animated material function
and embedding it into a massive material.
Pretty neat.
Have fun building some mass materials
and I'll see you soon.
Bye.